[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
atkinson for 10 o'clock is then
was he coming no so
dan uh we are at the moment we lose one
we're not
so we're quick um right so um
i put those apologies all those in favor
please say aye
against declare it carried thank you
item two conflicts of interest any of
those
for minuting no
confirmation of minutes from our meeting
of october the 8th
moved by councillor atkinson seconded by
councillor
williams all those in favor i put it all
those in favor please say aye
against declare it carried matters
arising from those minutes
no matters arising uh item five
deputation and presentations i don't
have any of those i don't think
all right now we're because we're going
to lose people
um in half an hour we're going to move
first deal with item 6.3
which is forrestdale wetland and i
invite
kate steele our ecologist to run us
through
that report over to you kate
hi so uh just uh just a couple of
changes um
because i've had some had some
discussions with the
owner of the adjoining lot and
environment canterbury staff since um
since i wrote the report and
we will only need to apply to immediate
steps for
30k and um costs instead of uh
36 as um the adjoining lot
owner has agreed to pay um
six yeah probably approximately 6k
towards the cost of that boundary fence
is that for over spraying
isn't it um yes so that's the that so
that's um
half that's half the cost of the uh
sort of the standard rural fence under
the fencing act for that section of
boundary
okay yes i was going to ask about that
if we're going to do fencing we actually
need to
to do uh something okay now continue
take us through it um
so the
yeah the um the proposal is that we
would
like to put a defense around the around
the wetland
um we received advice from um
a couple of ecologists that um we
need really that it's sort of really
important to
define the boundary where there is
currently no fence
and that a defense would um
sort of uh
provide
um yeah provide prediction from deer
that are coming into the wetland from
the mountain forest conservation area
and uh browsing the vegetation there and
impeding the regeneration
so that's why we yeah we'd be going for
a defense over a over a standard rural
fence
um and then there is a
sort of a significant amount of weed
control that needs to happen there
sort of um woody weeds like i think
there's sort of crack crack willow get
gray willow
um cherries hawthorne and
um what you what you can do there is if
you do a really sort of like good whack
of weed control
um then you can get your weeds down to
really low levels
um and you don't need a huge amount you
don't need to do a huge amount of
maintenance in order to keep the wetland
in really good condition
um and i mean this is a you know sort of
a really beautiful really significant
area and if we actually got there got
the wheat issues under control
got sort of supported the regeneration
to happen i think there's potential to
develop it into a really sort of lovely
wetland reserve that people in the
district could visit go for a walk and
put in some interpretation signage
develop it as a really sort of
nice place to be cool questions
councillors
just you mentioned the boundary do we
know what they are
or does part of this cost mean that we
have to survey to find out what the
boundary there are um there are survey
pigs um already installed along the top
of the terrace
yes yep um we also have agreement from
the adjoining lot owner to
put the fence and the sort of the most
cost-effective and practical line
regardless of whether that's on the
the land or island and um as a result of
that um
of that sort of forestry overspray we've
got um and the the follow-up that was
done after that we've got a really good
sort of
10 meter buffer between the um
end of our lot and the start
of the the plantation on that
yeah um on page 58
3.5 you've got fencing
etc wdc which is my macaroon district
council
ekm who's immediate stick
ah so immediate steps is um so the ecan
is from ecan's operational budget
and um immediate steps is from
environment canterbury's biodiversity
fund so there
is a hundred thousand dollars per annum
allocated for biodiversity projects in
our district
uh that generally goes to private
landowners but it has been used in the
past
to pay for um projects on
environment canterbury land and
department of conservation land
um yeah cool uh did you have a question
no okay oh yes and i'll
happy two seconds yes
thanks very much we got the last time
this just
clarified the points we wanted to know
so a great project and let's get on with
it
perfect excellent and my comment very
significant
uh wetland um the council's owned it
since 1999
and really has not done well by it and
it's also had overspray by the
from the forestry um company next door
so um i'm quite um happy to see that the
council
is putting some money into it finally
ecan has come forward with a
proposal from its operational budget
providing we spend it during the current
year
and the immediate steps fund which as
kate has explained
is a fund administered by the water zone
for biodiversity
enhancement projects is willing to come
well has indicated that this would be a
project they are certainly going to
consider favorably
and i'm really pleased to see that the
landowner has come forward as kate has
indicated with them
with uh sixth grade towards um the
fencing
so um yeah potentially very good result
all round anyone else got anything to
say
no right i
put it um all those in favor please say
oh
against declare it carry thank you very
much now we'll
we'll go to now um
we'll go to 6.1 shall we uh the
environmental programs
for the long term plan just to explain
we're going to lose
our core half an hour so we're just
flipping around a bit
his morning tea downstairs the mayor's
morning tea we're all going there at 10
o'clock
right over to you ladies to take us
through
um so last meeting
two months ago you might remember there
was a presentation about
a long-term plan like draft long-term
power and funding for environmental
projects and talked about five main
areas that we're looking at
just to give an overview so the zipper
projects
by domestic contestable fund our natural
reserves
and environmental education so the
report that's in 6.1 is
the details of that presentation
is still evolving there are a couple of
changes
that so management team are obviously
having to look for where to make
savings to be able to try and achieve
three percent or just over
rate rises so for example with the
zipper
project option b uh there's an
indication
um that there will be a reduction in
that option b
presented to council i think in january
is that right
jarrod it's probably worth
me just spending a minute on that yeah
so
the council has been providing funding
for the zipper implementation
to the tune of 100 000 per annum
and now well we did that for the first
year and then
last year just heading into locking in
the annual plan we halved that
because of covet to keep costs down
the council had only committed to it for
two years
so we were actually funding that on a
capitalized basis
so um which means uh
uh because we're capitalizing it that
pay that
cost actually gets spread out over quite
a few number of years into the future
um the approach we've taken in this
annual plan is
we're putting it up as a effectively
it's an
operational budget because it becomes a
recurring annual budget if the council
wishes to
continue to pursue that um but again we
have put the
50 uh lens over it so it's
um in the figures it'll come to you as
part of the
draft long term plan it'll be at that 50
level for your consideration um so a lot
of the reports you're getting today
uh um we've tried to line those up with
where
where the annual plan budgets are to
management teams actually still working
on those budgets so some of some of them
get a little bit out of sync
as we head into the end of the year
but but pretty much these are aligned
with the way the budgets are
going and you'll get your chance to
have a view of what impact all of these
are going to have in a
cumulative basis at the ltp
meeting but that just gives you a bit of
background on specifically on that
zipper implementation budget and so
we're proposing to put that forward and
that's a
reduction for the entire length of the
ltp
or is it uh yes it is correct yep
just a further clarification it was a
hundred thousand kpix and then there was
operational as well so that's looking at
a reduction from 100 000 capex to
50 000 um so that's that so there's also
that's why there's the number and option
two is um 310
and so that will be reduced um
by 260 does it yes but then also that
what's
going to happen is i think kate's
operation so so the ecologist
biodiversity role also might not come
under that budget anymore so the same
amount just slightly split slightly
differently but reduction of 50
000.
questions for the environment
for the environmental education budget
are we linking that with other
departments to the
of the council to see whether we're
going to keep that in house and
with over spread it over everybody
um i'll answer that in the first
instance and then
um kate and sophie might but just in
general we have carried out a
i'd call it a draft 17a review
and that was largely driven out of where
we spend most of our education which is
in solid waste
but there's also water and environmental
so we're actually
um we've put that on pause um
because until we actually know what the
council adopts in the ltp
overall for the council for education
purposes we really can't land that as
a definitive answer if this is the best
way to recommend going forward
so that
yes it all is in the mix from an
education point of view
but we are planning on making a decision
on the long-term service of education
uh following at the very least following
the draft annual
plan adoption by the council so
any further questions okay just
elaborate on the on that span of
of um what's in the education
environmental education package so we
are looking at including biodiversity
for the first time
from this ltp uh and bringing in
stormwater urban stormwater education um
there has been some funding for it but
actually bring it into a bit of a
program where you might actually
i don't know if i should talk about the
review but it might be potentially a
position
within council part-time uh rather than
a contractor role so those are the
discussions that have been
being had yeah okay
um i guess just the the other thing to
add is that um
one of one of the one of the options is
to
sort of significantly increase the
amount of support that we
provide to enviro schools in the
district as there are a number of
schools that would like to come on board
but they um
there's currently not the amount of
funding for the program to
yeah allow them all to participate thank
you
i'm happy to move the recommendations
a second councillor williams um
seconds yes extensive
program um outlined here um
one thing i would like consideration
given to us
renaming the biodiversity contestable
fund to something that is more
explanatory like waimakariri
biodiversity enhancement
fund or whatever something to think
about
because biodiversity contestable fund
means not a lot out in the greater
population
but as i said understand
that the drive to
cut back don't necessarily agree that it
should be for the entire length of the
ltp but that's a discussion for the ltp
so happy as i said happy to move it and
thank you very much
um for the work that has gone into
preparing this counselor nothing further
from counsellor williams so i i
put the recommendations all those in
favor please say aye
with that adjustment that um jared has
mentioned on the um on the budget for
the zipper
implementation down from 100k to
about 50k for the capital works part of
it
okay um i'll put it all those will
favorably say
against declare it carried thank you
right now we'll go to 6.2
which is um sophie again drainage
activities in wetland areas
so kiara we probably um you might have
heard about
uh some freshwater regulations that came
in at the end of
uh in september this year um so the nes
the national environmental standards for
fresh water
is one of those um like one of the
packages that
came in that was deseeded in september
and it does introduce rules that are now
currently operative for our wetlands
and not just for the wetland but also
some rules
in the 100 meter buffers around so
slightly different rules for the hundred
meter buffers but uh in trying to
interpret
these rules uh there's currently quite a
lot of confusion to be quite honest
you might have sensed that from the
report we are working as much as
possible to
to gain clarity both from environment
canterbury and mfv
so at the moment this report is for
information uh only and it just
yeah it's going to be an evolving area
as we get more clarity
what we are really sure on is that we as
a council our works
drainage works come under specified
infrastructure which is a
so that if a person a private individual
which is to undertake works within a
wetland
um they are not able to access those
those um they're not able to qualify as
specified infrastructure whereas our
drainage works because they are under
the
flood protection and river control act
something that we are able to
to um to be specified infrastructure so
therefore
works are able to be carried out within
wetlands that
if we are able to meet the conditions
and the conditions is where it comes
where it's confusing because um it talks
about not being able to change the depth
of the waterway or change
depth of the wetland sorry or the
hydrological regime and that's quite
hard to do if you're doing drainage
works you will you will be changing
for more than 30 days the intention of
drainage works would be to change the
the depth or the hydrological regime but
is it that
is the interpretation saying just the
bed of the drain or is it also the
sediment
on top of the bit of the drain so this
is where we don't know this is the
the um where the confusion comes in um
for our position this summer we are
looking at only carrying out what we are
quite certain as our permitted works so
this is such as removing of
of watercress and other kinds of
weeds in the way in the drains but not
any works where we are
removing sediment or creating or
widening any drains
it hasn't really delayed anything this
summer
we hadn't actually anticipated any any
works
the summit had to be cancelled because
of the nes but it would be fair to say
that we probably would
we might have carried out something this
summer that we
and if we continue to delay um next year
as well then there would be
an issue so it is something we need to
address into the long term about
which uh what scent to carry out
uh it's not covered under our drainage
and minor works and waterways
consents sorry maintenance of minor
works and waterways consent
because the nes came in quite late in
negotiating that consent we decided to
exclude
any works in wetlands so we would need
to seek individual consents
what i'm looking at doing is a test case
where we
seek consent potentially for the lion
side road wetland area
to carry out drainage works and to see
what response we get from ecan and
interpreting the nes
regulations or legislation so another
point that i have in the report is that
we need more information from ministry
for the environment
and from ecan they have issued the fact
sheet that was an appendix to
to the report but it doesn't
specifically talk about drainage
it's it's they're still at the higher
level um and
like i mentioned at the start we've had
a whole lot of legislation regulations
come out
around winter grazing and stock
exclusion that
it's pretty fair to say that you can
have really focused on trying to get the
information out of those
issues and work in wetlands will
will be something that they will turn
their focus to when they get
the ability to great happy to take any
questions
you've got the area of um saltwater
creek in here and down at kairaki
how does that affect the trust and their
plans for uh for what they're doing with
the sections down there and
or the existing people who live there
given that there's near 100 metre buffer
on the lower reaches of saltwater creek
so this is where there are slightly
different rules for the buffer areas
so private landowners are able to carry
out works within
the buffer areas they might need a
consent whereas within a wetland area it
is prohibited for them
which is that that is a change from from
the land of water regional plan rules
where they would have
applied for a consent to carry out works
within the wetland but because they're
within the buffer area they can still
apply for a consent
it might be slightly different rules
than
the different slightly different
conditions that they have to meet
have we talked to the trust about this
particular area considering we know
what their intention is so i'm not
actually sure what they're
you mean with the housing and
yeah i think and the existing people who
live there yeah i think i would need to
look at a map to understand where the
buffer area is
what i have looked at is for our council
works within
the kairaki saltwater creek area that
it is it has been confirmed on the
ground by you can as a wetland area
on the wetland mapping but that's not a
planning map
but we're assuming that if there was a
planning map it would be also
classified as a wetland so that means
that we are as a council we are able to
undertake works but private landowners
would have
if they had any wheatland on their
property yeah can i suggest
jared that we do some work on this for
the existing owners and the trust
and at least inform them of this rule
that's in there because i'll bet you
my bottom dollar they've got no idea
thank i'm just talking about the line
side road
bramley road wetland so am i
understanding this correctly the owner
of that property is saying that
this wasn't a wetland until you guys
didn't maintain the drain and it flooded
my property and turned it into a wetland
is that what they're saying
yes there are multiple owners in that
area so there is um
yeah there definitely are um we have
received emails or
you know verbally we've had meetings
saying this if you had if you hadn't if
you had carried out maintenance
on the strain before the the wetland
regulations came in
it wouldn't be flooding as it does i
think what um
we do have to acknowledge that the area
is a basin and it is challenging to
drain it's possible that some properties
no matter what you do you'd have to pump
to to remove water in some places uh
it's so it's a bit complex
if yeah i don't know we also have dan
lewis here today
who's been looking at the different
levels there so
i mean if you wanted to comment as well
you're welcome too i think it's a
slippery slope being that that entire
area was drained swamp basically so
um yeah i guess that's how far back do
you want to go and on that same note my
next question is when you're talking
about getting clarification from ecan
with regards to changing a drain
due to maintenance are we saying
that it's just maintenance to return it
to what it was or
we can't change it from what it is prior
to the maintenance
being undertaken rather
from what it's become i guess because it
hasn't been maintained for a while
so that's exactly where the confusion
comes in of is it i think from
understanding
my understanding of the legislation it's
as of it was because of the condition it
was
at of the third of september this year
um
i don't think we could say look if you
go back 10 20 years it was this
this shape or yeah i think it is but
this is the one it's not clear
um from and is it removing the sediment
but not the actual base
um the sediment that's built up that's
that's come into the wetland area is
that is that considered
not changing the shape of the drain or
is it
considered changing the shape so this is
where we don't understand
because that could make it problematic
as well because obviously if we haven't
had a chance to get in and clean a drain
for a long time then
it's not actually acting as effectively
as it was originally meant to because
the falls and what not will have changed
due to the sedimentation which needs to
be removed so it can actually
work as it's intended interesting okay
thank you
yeah just on that given the legislation
states that if it's if the waterway is
naturally formed
um then it is a waterway if it's if it's
man-made then it is not
under under legislation how does that
fit with the natural waterway even if it
is
500 years back that's actually naturally
formed
it's been changed by man it doesn't
change the status
this is my mind thinking here it doesn't
change the status that it's a natural
waterway
and if you take the reverse of that
legislation says that if anything is
formed by man then it is not a natural
waterway
so we just the mps turning this on this
year because i'd like some clarification
around that because that's just not
i'd suggest if that was tested in in the
environment court there could
in fact be some very real issue around
that particular point
it is yeah most definitely an issue
about what is natural and what is
artificial um
yeah they have been um i'm not sure if
it was a court case but definitely
interpretation from ecan
that certain waterways that we're
replacing if you
put a drain through a wetland they're
saying that the drain then becomes a
natural waterway because it's replacing
a natural structure
but uh example madam chair the example
is around
um the kyboy lakes when we went to put
legislation in there under the swimming
pool act
those lakes technically under law need
to be
fenced because they're an altered
waterway that was done by men
and they there's no way in legislation
you can
change them to a natural lake
you just can't do it even though that's
what i mean you could argue
now that's what they are you can't do
that legislation states that you can't
do that
but what we're saying is the opposite
we're saying that the natural waterway
if it's 50 60 years ago isn't taken in
account
to do what we want to do here i'm not
you i'm not saying you
but that's the that's the complication
that i see in this and i think we need
to be really careful around that
just a question thank you for myself um
bearing in mind that you're talking
kairaki and
taranaki stream where
the ecan overhead maps
create a wetland um the drainage of
kairaiki creek came up at um the
planning meeting
uh last week and i'm i'm go
are we going to address this particular
these two
areas and have meetings with
the locals because some of the locals at
kairaki
take the drainage of saltwater creek on
upon themselves
and i was shown pictures of they've gone
and dug up
wetland plants to allow the flow of
the creek so i was going to
ask exactly perhaps dan might like to
comment also on um my second question is
i thought that the there was drainage
work
done uh online side road area
as much as um the council staff felt
confident that
that was what they could do when this
and that's relatively recently because i
can
see that see that the sediment that
you've taken out
so you're talking about further work
was there further work that um you
planned i thought
we'd done as much as we were able to do
yeah so we have worked outside of that
hundred metre buffer
along line side road from the area that
is mapped as wetland on the ecan
wetland map there are the area areas
within the wetland that
dan louis wood has confirmed as you know
as land drainage engineer he would
um clear take out sediment if if um if
there wasn't what's in there
if that was within you know without so
we would be seeking a consent for that
but at the moment um
we're not carrying out that work yes
okay and is there any movement from
landowners there they weren't allowing i
i note
this report seems to be behind the top
behind what has subsequently happened in
some some aspects
um the landowners weren't letting you
can on to
their sites to ground truth
the wetland status so there's an update
there yeah
yeah so uh yesterday the ecologist went
and visited four
of the properties uh which
so unfortunately not probably not there
are two key properties which have
a small significant area of the wetland
i'm not sure if maybe one of them might
have been i'm not sure exactly which
properties but definitely one didn't
have
that survey because they chose not to
have the ecologist visit
that's the ecan ecologist yeah okay
so it's ongoing
all right well i'm i'm happy to move um
the recommendations which are mostly
noting
various aspects of the new um
new freshwater package and how it
applies to our drainage works
particularly around wetlands secondly
that actually states we're going to
consult with the with the people
um if we could add another one in there
it could be that we are going to consult
with the affected parties
yeah apologies is that was a good point
that councillor stewart made about
making sure we do particularly in these
key areas that we're that we're
identifying to start
you know we have already held meetings
with the line side road
whitland uh so similar similar kind of
open meetings where we
will contact landowners to come okay
i'll i'll add a um
staff will note notes that staff will
consult and engage with affected parties
in the
key areas
yes and i'm happy to add that in um
i think that thank you so it's just
speaking to
it that particularly
struck me because of what is going on
particularly down at salt water creek
and i think sooner
than later uh the council needs to
go and have a chat to both and i don't
know
the extent of the lower taranaki stream
wetland
but i suspect um that that needs to be
[Music]
uh talked about with community board and
any other landowners
in the area and particularly for for
saltwater creek
because as i said made aware that um
there was criticism of the council and
its lack of
drainage maintenance in the area um and
that may
of course be prior to the mps
but um now there is even a greater
constraint
and i think that the locals need to know
where um where things are at the moment
and particularly
if we haven't had talks with tu haitara
we need to do that urgently
apart from that um yes uh
and i do i do mention that um
from what i understand we have um apart
from the
areas particularly affected by the new
mps that we have a
a minor works and maintenance network
consent ticked off by ecan
finally finally or do we well the
instructions were to
to grant their consent i'm not sure if
that has been processed yet okay
any update from the benches there
you haven't anything more from um ecan
on the consent
no yeah okay
thank you
councilman just i intend on voting for
this but before we do we have a question
um your concerns that you've raised with
saltwater creek also
questions like that have arisen in the
hookah
rural drainage advisory board group
it's a mouthful as well you know as to
what can and can't be done and there was
some rather heated discussion i'm sure
daniel remember
about what we can and can't do around
wetlands
i note nj it says notes a need for
community education and engagement to
support our communities understanding of
this issue particularly through
community boards and drainage boards now
what exactly do we mean by
that are we expecting the community
boards and drainage boards to get the
word out or is this going to be
supported by an education
from council an educational plan because
from my experience the community boards
and drainage boards don't really
sort of get out there into the community
and tell people
things perhaps they should but
there doesn't really seem to be a whole
lot of support for that kind of
approach so how will we do this
well i think if we do provide support
for the drainage advisory group
and groups and community boards such as
the materials
it could be a role that they might not
have done traditionally but they are in
well placed to do
so i think it could be something that we
do as long as we support them that we do
we do work with the existing structures
we have
yeah i would just say that if we do that
with it we please have a bit more of a
coordinated approach with that so that
people can actually take that on board
and understand that that is
the intention for them to actually get
the word out because otherwise i don't
think that it will
be disseminated in the way that we hope
thank you
i just might in writer reply i'll take
it up
um i think the wetlands mapping that
ecan
has has got that is what this council is
sort of defaulting to
in the in this period of uncertainty
that needs to be readily available to
all our
drainage advisory groups and while the
recommendation
here in k says that community education
will be discussed as part of the ltp i
think
that we need to move earlier than that
to get this information out to our
drainage advisory groups and those
particular areas that
are front and center um
for the council thank you
all right i'll put that all in favor
please say i
against declare it carried thank you
so much ripping off
and we've got um
wow end of the year
um yes the only thing outstanding is our
briefing um and i think it's still
of interest to um to the rest of the
committee you're going to yeah
yes yes okay well we're
portfolio updates number seven um
myself with biodiversity um
isn't um a lot to report that hasn't
been
um already in the agenda
apart from the fact that the water zone
committee um
its biodiversity group continues to
develop
a waimakariri well looking at
how to bring into effect a waimakariri
and biodiversity
trust that would
be looking for funding to carry out
and work like tiara kakariki does and
selwyn
so that's ongoing they haven't come up
with a
proposal um to date and we've got um
that's about it for me um we are
just adding waiting for the um
biodiversity mps that will be coming
through in april
from the government um uh our
um council black isn't here to update us
on land bank
based indigenous reserves including
river margins
so i moved to um questions of which i
have none
urgent general business of which i have
none our next meeting will be
february the 16th and i close the
meeting
at 1007 and thank you for your
attendance
and it was very quick